et
[Musique]
tous les shadoks notes ont été faits
prisonniers avec les uns les gibbons ont
fait des conserves pour gégène les
autres ils les ont emmenés chez eux pour
s'en occuper
[Musique]
l'egypte vit d'abord les tester à ceux
reconnus les plus aptes ont confié le
soin de menus travaux ménagers mais ça
en corse était rien
ceux de la catégorie en dessous était
réservée à l'amusement
[Musique]
messieurs de la troisième catégorie des
courts 20e passé à la petite boîte à la
petite boîte cosmique jbe c'était encore
un nouveau jeu qu'ils avaient inventé
ont branché le chat d'oc sur la petite
boîte et hop ça vous le transformer en
n'importe quoi en briguant marque tôt en
monuments historiques
il est jbe parier sur ceux qui
sortiraient après l'essai s'entraîner ou
quatre coins de la terre il n'était pas
mort l'adorent marquis non simplement
des gt et oui des shadoks
voilà tout ce qu'ils vont rester
c'était triste quand même et les uns
dans des boîtes de conserve des autres
changer en jouet ou un objet ménager
tous ces malheureux shadoks bafouée et
humiliée attendait la rage au coeur
qu'on vienne un jour les délivrer mais
là bas chez eux sur la lune plus un des
leurs ne répondait il était il perdu à
tout jamais
[Musique]